salut aujourd'hui juste apprendre
comment retoucher des photos instagram
mais avant toute chose on va se faire un
petit café au très bon aujourd'hui on va
parler d'instagram je sais pas si tu es
sur instagram et pour moi c'est devenu
mon réseau social préféré loin devant
snapshot snapshot j'aime bien mais le
côté temporaire c'est moi mon truc je
crois que facebook saveljic ça devient
moins sympa et que vraiment instagram
april avance alors on sait qu'un style g
appartient facebook mais que vraiment la
communication par l'image au travers
d'un stade g c'est vraiment génial
j'adore ça et aujourd'hui sept filets
les meilleures astuces pour apprendre
réellement à éditer et à faire des plus
belles photos sur instagram
c'est hyper simple il suffit d'être bien
outillé d'abord un peu de méthode et tu
vas voir dès que tu as compris comment
ça marche c'est extrêmement facile
tiens d'ailleurs si tu regardes ça c'est
probablement compter sur instagram je
vais donc d'inviter handfield sur
instagram
comme ça au moins on reste en contact
instagram tout c'est de la communication
par l'image c'est simple je t'apprends
rien discret comment ça marche la toute
première chose à savoir sur instagram la
toute première chose avant même de
commencer à vouloir éviter c'est d'avoir
une belle photo si t'as pas une belle
photo tu n'en feras absolument rien elle
doit être impeccable
si ta base elle est pas bonne tu pourras
faire ce que tu veux c'est pas de la
magie des logiciels ne font pas de magie
tu auras une photo pourri et tu feras
des bricoles dessus ça n'ira pas donc on
va voir déjà comment faire une bonne
photo et ensuite juste montrer comment
les dit tu es et tu verras franchement
c'est hyper simple on va commencer avec
ce qu'on a
regarde là tu vois j'ai mon mec
barcelona qui est un vieux souvenir
et justement et on va en profiter
justement on va la prendre en photo et
on va bosser là dessus je vais te
montrer comment éditer ce mug et faire
une photo qui déchire sa race
à partir de ce mode après allez on y va
toute première chose à faire c'est faire
une belle photo
je vais positionner mon maigre barcelona
ici prendre l'iphone on appuie dessus
pour faire l'âne est têtu la luminosité
on peut la bouger légèrement mais on
reparlera après c'est pas la peine une
fois qu'on est ok photo et on a la photo
dans la boîte et on va bosser là dessus
stop
donc on y va le principe qui pèse autant
d'iphone c'est hyper simple il ya deux
applications à télécharger la toute
première ça va être celle là
snap sida snapsy je la conseille pour re
la faire de la retouche d'image c'est
hyper simple snapsy en réalité si tu
veux c'est un peu le photoshop mais de
google
et tu peux aussi utiliser photoshop
express directement ce qui faire des
retouches
ça marche aussi très bien moi ce que je
te conseille fondamentalement c'est une
abside qui est le logiciel qui est le
plus simple alors snap side tu vas up
dans les moments on va prendre le
dernier mode qu'on a fait en photo et là
on va bosser directement là dessus donc
on appuie là on est dit on va commencer
par faire les retouches alors dans un
premier temps on va faire la luminosité
tubes à l'oeil d'un côté ou de l'autre
tu vois ça change ta luminosité dans
l'entente up luminosité là on est sans
immunité visiter 0 pas la peine de
l'augmenter c'est très lumineux on peut
même la baisser légèrement ensuite tu as
pu être choisi contraste le contrat
c'est hyper important sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que ça va porter vraiment
du punch à ta photo donc ton contraste
tu peux le booster un petit peu c'est
tout cas on a du rouge
voilà alors là c'est un peu violent mais
tu vois regarde déjà ça nous apporte
vraiment quelque chose ça fait ressortir
un peu les couleurs sur le nèg situes tu
n'as 0 c'est un peu plus tout pâle
latule monte ça te faire monter un peu
les couleurs les couleurs du mug bon
c'est un peu violent mais ça marche
ensuite on continue la saturation pareil
pour apporter de la sat et colorisé un
petit peu l'histoire ça marche ou pas y
aller trop fort sur la salle sinon c'est
rapidement trop trop violent l'ambiance
ça fonctionne aussi pour monter un peu
les rouges qui voient derrière
l'arrière-plan
il a un peu craqué en plus mon club soit
un côté un peu brillant ça marche très
bien si tu veut clair certes et on clair
on n'y a pas grande pompe l'air donc
c'est vraiment juste leblanc
d'arrière-plan mais nous on veut pas y
toucher ça nous intéresse pas les ombres
c'est intéressant ça peut effectivement
apporté aussi quelque chose à ton image
moi je les enlève un petit peu pour
noircir mmm bug ça marche très bien et
apporter de la chaleur
tu vas mettre un petit peu un côté un
peu plus soit bleu tu l'enlèves se tire
un peu sur le jeune légèrement pour
apporter de la chaleur
donc ça tu vois c'est quelques réglages
qui sont hyper simple que tu peux faire
dès le départ ensuite dans les détails
moi ce que je te conseille de regarder
ça avec la structure savez tout ce qui
va être un petit peu comment te dire tu
vas voir rapidement le point de détail
si je l'enlève sa milice mon cuir kit ou
granuleux et si je le monte
ça me fait ressentir toutes les
craquelures donc six wagons que tu
travailles sur des choses un peu
culinaire tu faire ressortir un petit
peu les détails de tavillons des choses
comme ça tu peux moi par contre j'ai
aucun intérêt à montrer que mon canapé
est abîmée donc je baisse ma structure
ça me liste à son site un mug sa malice
alors pas trop violent non plus et
pareil après pour la netteté
c'est pendant que ce soit trop net j'ai
besoin quelque chose d'un petit peu plus
sousse tu vois structure up
si tu vas vers le haut et vers le bas tu
choisis dans son menu donc droit de
gauche qui modifie les paramètres au
battle choisi le menu la netteté
j'ai pas besoin de la montée moi
personnellement ça va très bien comme ça
et je valide ici ensuite recadrage bon
tu peux recadrer si tu veut croquer un
peu ton image si j'estime qu'on voit un
petit peu trop ici mon fauteuil hop hop
hop hop me fait un faux car elles
stockent instagram c'est du carré donc
vraiment garder une proportion car et
voit la jolie mugs ensuite un truc qui
est super sympa bon la balance des
blancs si tu veux module est aussi un
petit blanc tu as température la
coloration les choses comme ça tu peux
complètement modules et moi ce que je te
conseille de regarder après ça va être
la transformation tu peux rajouter la
perspective verticale donc là il un peu
plus vers le haut d'inspecter
comme si tu le prenais un peu plus bas
ou d'un peu plus haut en fonction de ce
que tu veux faire de ce que tu veux
donner à ton image ça peut être pas mal
bon personnellement sur cette image des
prises de façade va bien dans la
perspective aussi horizontal qui marche
tu le veux un peu plus à droite ou un
petit peu plus à gauche
ça corrige super bien c'est très doux et
ça marche vraiment bien personnellement
là dessus je vais pas en remettre
ce qui est bien c'est la courbe c'est
tout nouveau tu va modifier un petit
blanc et noirs hop
alors est ce que tu veux venir avec moi
voilà tu peux modifier sa courbe
légèrement vers le haut et l'a
légèrement vers le bas
ça te fait un résultat qui généralement
ne marche pas trop mal kif pas ou ne
soit pas trop violent sur la cour
bavarde sinon c'est tout de suite
dégueulasse
un truc très très léger et ça marche
très bien le vignettage si tu le
souhaites voilà tu peux faire pas mal de
choses il ya différentes solutions
tu vas sur cet outil là qui est vraiment
tout simplement extraordinaire ensuite
si tu veux ya des filtres qui existent
déjà que tu peux utiliser
pourquoi pas ça marche plutôt bien une
fois que tu as fini tu sentes en images
tu enregistres tu exporte tu vois ton
image ça c'est l'image modifié et à
l'image de base c'est vraiment pas la
même chose
c'est beaucoup plus fade les couleurs
ressortent moins tandis que sur celles
que j'ai modifié
tu vois que c'est tout de suite beaucoup
plus punchy et tout de suite
forcément sur instagram ça va attirer
l'oeil et les gens auront plus
facilement tendance soit à liker soit
cliquer dessus à mettre un commentaire
parce que ta photo les plus punchy
maintenant on va faire une dernière
chose on va utiliser un autre logiciel
qui marche super bien que je te
conseille qui apportent vraiment une
touche artistique c'est celui-là laisse
distortion ça c'est juste extraordinaire
on va reprendre notre photo up qui a été
modifiée qui est celle ci et là tu vas
pouvoir ajouter des effets alors tu
choisis un effet de lumière on regarde
par exemple celui là est un centre
ajoute une lumière tu vois alors là mais
pas là c'est too much par contre tu peux
effectivement l'agrandir et la diminuer
faire comme s'il y avait un effet de
soleil directement sur ta photo tu vois
ça marche super bien
bon surtout que moi la fenêtre elle est
plus de ce côté là alors celui-là il
n'est pas extraordinaire mais alors tu
as plein de choses tu peux ajouter un
petit côté artistique saute dessus
pareil hop on a grandi ça ça marche
plutôt bien
tu vois ça apporte quelque chose à la
photo c'est très sympa il ya là
plusieurs ça s'est un peu plus chaud ça
peut aussi marcher tulle a grandi et une
mis sur le côté ça va vraiment apporter
un peu de la chaleur à ton image surtout
pneus en naissant la thématique
barcelone donc il faut du show après tu
vois un tas d la fumée bon ça c'est
rapidement en coco mais ça dépend ce que
tu veux mettre comme ambiance
c'est une fin délire halloween au film
d'horreur tu peux rajouter ce genre de
filtres comme si tu avais des petites
taches sur ton sur ton appareil aussi
c'est vraiment sympa on fait plein de
choses avec st
après tu peux acheter des filtres en
plus je vois pas particulièrement
l'intérêt d'autant plus sur ce quota de
base pour l'utilisation sur instagram ça
marche déjà très bien donc moi ce que je
te conseille c'est de prendre
moi je suis un tout chaud donc je prends
quelque chose comme ça un petit peu
chaud je vais me le mettre sur le côté
et voilà barcelone a un peu de soleil je
les augmenter je veux mais la pac soit
ou mèche et tout de suite ça apporte
vraiment quelque chose et ensuite tu
cliques là tu enregistres en images elle
est enregistrée et tu retournes
directement up dans tes photos et là tu
peux regarder ta photo modifié et si tu
compare avec la première c'est clair que
il ya une grosse différence la photo de
base et maintenant la photo modifié tu
vois ça n'a rien à voir alors là je te
les faits sur les photos de mode toute
conne mais après tu peux vraiment à
faire sur ce que tu veux tu vois au
final c'est hyper facile de faire des
bonnes photos sur instagram tu prends
une bonne photo faisant plusieurs à la
limite comme souvent par un peu de recul
tu peux choisir la meilleure part nous
tout
ensuite tous choisi le logiciel que tu
veux pour l'éditer ça peut être
photoshop ça peut être une abside comme
tu veux ensuite un coup d'oeil
distortion pour vraiment apporter
quelque chose à porter une luminosité
apporter une lumière est vraiment
ajouter un côté créatif tu export tu la
mets sur instagram peut mettre un peu de
vignettes corrigeait légèrement la
luminosité tempête pas plus pas de
filtre instagram rien tu envoies
directement et aura une photo magnifique
et après si tu veux vraiment réussir sur
instagram
il faut vraiment que tu es un compte
instagram qui soit cohérent il faut que
ce soit vraiment cohérent
que tu parles toujours la même chose
avec des mots clés choisis et ça on en
repart à une prochaine fois c'est
vraiment comme ça que tu pourras réussir
parce que tu as beau poster les plus
belles photos du monde s'il ya personne
pour les voir ça ne marchera pas donc
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo tu as
plus en tout cas si elle t'a plu ce que
tu fais c'est humain jolie poussent vers
le haut dis moi à toi on compte
instagram comment tu l'utilisent que tu
fais avec mes moyens
résumons compte instagram en commentaire
j'irai voir les images gérer voire un
petit peu à quoi ça ressemble ça me
permettra un petit peu de découvrir ton
univers et sait-on jamais tu pourras
peut-être même abonnés fêtant jamais
abonne toi toi de ton côté de la chaîne
youtube mais moi un commentaire rejoins
moi et surtout un grand merci pour avoir
regardé cette vidéo est allé à la tienne
tueuse